president Trump's newest attack on
robert muller and the russia
investigation is raising the prospect of
a confrontation with the special counsel
the president tour in the Moller last
night after federal prosecutors in New
York City ordered a raid on his longtime
attorney Michael Cohen the president is
you're heard called it a disgrace some
of the evidence seized involves Cohen's
payment of one hundred and thirty
thousand dollars to adult film actress
stormy Daniels who claims she had sex
with mr. Trump in 2006 major Garrett is
at the White House major good morning
good morning this is quite clearly the
president sharpest public criticism of
Special Counsel Robert Muller now mr.
Trump's loyalists have been arguing in
public for weeks that Muller ought to be
fired and it sounds as if mr. Trump is
giving that more serious consideration
than ever or as in the past he could
just be blowing off steam
it's a disgraceful situation it's a
total witch hunt I've been saying it for
a long time president Trump lashed out
at Special Counsel Robert Muller and is
expanding Russia investigation after a
Monday meeting with top military
officials it's a an attack on our
country in the true sense it's an attack
on what we all stand for an FBI raid of
the New York offices of mr. Trump's
personal attorney Michael Cohen whom the
president called a quote good man
apparently triggered the tirade one of
the FBI raids took place on the 23rd
floor of 30 Rockefeller Plaza at the law
firm where Cohen had been working
sources tell CBS News that at 9:15 a.m.
yesterday morning two or three FBI
agents first showed up followed by more
investigators they spent a few hours
combing through Cohen's office Cohen's
personal residence at Trump Park Avenue
was subject to the search as was a third
location a Lowe's Regency Hotel in New
York City where Cohen had been staying
they find no collusion and then they go
from there and they say well let's keep
going and they raid an office of a
personal attorney early in the morning
so we'll be talking about it more but
this is the most conflicted group of
people I've ever seen mr. Trump again
assailed attorney general Jeff sessions
for recusing himself in the Russia probe
calling the decision based on Department
ethics advice a quote terrible mistake
he should have certainly let us know if
he was going to recuse himself and we
would have used a put a different
Attorney General in because sessions
recused himself Muller reports to trump
appointed Deputy Attorney General Rod
Rosenstein the FBI raid on Cohen's
office was in all likelihood approved by
Rosenstein the president declined to say
what actions he might take ominously the
president noted people have told him to
fire Muller while the president cannot
fire Muller himself he could order
Rosenstein to remove the Special Counsel
again they found nothing and in finding
nothing that's a big statement of course
we don't know what if anything was found
we do know this raid of Cohen's office
and property comes in a particularly
awkward time for the president's legal
team they were in the final stages they
thought of negotiation with Muller and
his team about an interview with
President Trump this rate of Cohen's
office and residents casts a pall over
those conversations viana quite a
surprise for many people major thank you